the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture for today have entitled
logarithms without exponents and before
I try to clarify that let me make a
couple of general remarks first of all
we have now completed the rudiments the
basic so to speak of both differential
and integral calculus consequently what
our next ambition will be is to take
these principles and apply them to
special functions which are worthy of
investigation and you see in connection
with this the first function that I've
chosen to talk about is called the
logarithm now the other interesting
thing is that we are used to logarithms
from high school where they were viewed
as being a different kind of notation
for talking about exponents now in the
same way when we treated the circular
functions we mentioned that one did not
have to invent triangles to talk about
trigonometry the interesting point is
that one does not have to talk about
exponents to invent the logarithm
function this is why I've entitled the
lesson as I say logarithms without
exponents you see what I would like to
do is try to mimic especially from an
engineering point of view how many of
these mathematical topics originated
let's look at a rather straightforward
physical principle a principle that I'm
sure we believe permeates many real-life
situations it's what I call the the rule
of compound interest namely let's
suppose we have a physical situation in
which the quantity that we're measuring
which we'll call m in other words the
rate of change of the quantity is
proportional to the amount present DM DT
equals km now notice that this is a
pretty harmless statement the rate of
change is proportional to the amount
present we certainly would expect that
many experiments would run this way and
there seems to be nothing at all
supernatural about this kind of an
assumption at any rate let's apply our
previous principles and see if we can't
from this differential equation figure
out what M has to be except
the variables we get that DM over m is
equal to K DT and now integrating
meaning taking the inverse derivative we
have what that the integral of DM over
is equal to KT plus a constant now you
see the interesting point is at this
stage of the game we do not know
explicitly how to find a function whose
derivative with respect to M is 1 over m
in fact that's the problem that
underlies today's lecture and we will
try to answer this question
showing how once we tackle this from a
philosophic point of view the rest of
the details follow from material that
we've already learned at any rate
focusing our attention on the problem
the question is this to determine a
function which I'll call capital L of X
the L sort of to forewarn us of the fact
that we will somehow get a logarithm out
of this such that L prime of X is 1 over
X and you see what I want you to notice
is that if you write 1 over X in
exponential form in other words if you
try to write 1 over X as X to the N
notice that to solve this problem L of X
would be 1 the integral of X to the
minus 1 DX in other words this is the
case of integral X to the n DX with n
equal to minus 1 and you recall that
when we studied the recipe let me just
write that over here when we studied the
recipe of how you integrate X to the N
we saw that that was X to the n plus 1
over n plus 1 plus a constant and we
then observe that this doesn't even make
sense
when n is equal to minus 1 because we
have a 0 denominator through other point
of view the way to look at this is we
said what that when you differentiate
you lower the exponent by 1 notice that
to wind up with an exponent of minus 1
we would have had to start with an
exponent of 0 but when you differentiate
X to the 0 that being a constant the
derivative of X to the 0
is zero it's not 1 over X you see in
other words this particular recipe that
we were talking about we don't have
working for us in other words this is an
interesting point again you say gee whiz
if the recipe for integral x to the MDX
works for everything except n equals
minus 1 nothing's perfect let's be
content since this works for every
number except that one why worry this is
analogous to when we talked about taking
derivatives and saw that we get a 0 over
0 form every time you see if you pick a
function at random the likelihood at the
limit of f of X as X approaches a the
likelihood of that being 0 over 0 is
very small except when you form the
derivative you always get 0 over 0 and a
similar way granted that integral X to
the minus 1 DX is 1 very special case
what we have seen is that this comes up
every single time that we want to solve
a problem of the form DM DT equals km in
other words then when it really boils
down to is that unless we can come up
with a function L of X whose derivative
is 1 over X we cannot solve the problem
that we started off today's lesson with
in other words we must leave it in the
form integral DM over M equals KT plus a
constant well at any rate let's see what
such a function capital L of X must look
like I'm going to utilize both the
differential calculus approach and the
integral calculus approach by integral
calculus differential calculus assuming
that y equals L of X what do we know
about the function y by definition we've
defined it to be that function whose
derivative is 1 over X so we know it's
derivative is 1 over X the next point is
that knowing that y prime is 1 over X
and even though we can't integrate 1
over X we can certainly differentiate 1
over X we can now differentiate 1 over X
the derivative of 1 over X is minus 1
over x squared and we find that y double
prime is minus 1 over x squared by the
way we should observe that we must shy
away from
equaling zero because you see we would
have a zero denominator in that case if
we think of most physical situations
notice that when we talk about the
amount the rate of change is
proportional to the amount present from
a physical point of view the amount
present can't be negative so let's put
the restriction on here that the domain
of L will be all positive numbers okay
now here's the interesting thing
intuitively I can now visualize how the
function L of X must look namely since
its first derivative is 1 over X and X
is greater than 0 that tells me that the
curve is always rising and secondly
since 1 over x squared is always
positive minus 1 over x squared is
always negative that tells me that my
curve is always spilling water in
essence then what must the curve do the
curve must be rising but spilling water
in other words the curve L of X belongs
to this particular family notice that
once we have one curve which we call y
equals L of x by any displacement
parallel to vertical displacement we get
what a member called
y equals L of X plus C all the changes
is what the point at which the curve
crosses the x-axis but whichever member
of the family we pick what typifies L of
X its derivative is 1 over X in other
words somehow or other we visualize that
L of X exists and it's graph is
something like this ok now suppose we
want a more tangible form namely how do
you compute L of X for a given X I
thought what might be a nice review now
is to see how we can use our integral
calculus approach and in particular the
second fundamental theorem of integral
calculus
by the integral calculus approach what
we do is is we pick any positive number
a and once picked we fix it you see we
have a great deal of freedom in how we
choose the number the positive number a
but let's pick one and leave it here now
what we'll do is in the YT plane we'll
draw the curve y equals 1 over T C and
what we do now we'll study the area of
the region R where R is bounded above by
y equals 1 over T on the left by T
equals ay on the right by T equals x and
below by the T axis now we've already
seen that the function that we get by
taking the definite integral from a to X
DT over T has the property that its
derivative is 1 over X in other words
recall from the fundamental theorem this
is general just a generalization of the
fact that if f of T is a continuous
function then the integral from a to X F
of T DT is a function of X and it's
derivative with respect to X is just f
of X you see in other words I can now
view capital L of X as being an area
under the curve y equals 1 over T notice
that I have a degree of freedom here
namely what that area is depends on
where I choose a notice that if I choose
a differently changing a let's call this
a prime say changing a changes the area
under the curve but notice the changes
that by a fixed amount in other words
notice that shifting a just changes L of
X by a constant just like the ordinary
indefinite integral
at any rate these are the two approaches
that we have and if we superimpose them
all we're saying is what if you start
with a differential calculus approach y
equals capital L of X must be a member
of this family crossing the axis at some
point a comma zero and from the integral
calculus point of view if you take the
curve y equals 1 over T and compute the
area under that curve
from a to X that area function is L of X
okay now we'll let that rest for the
time being and now have a brief
digression you see sooner or later I've
got to get to what a logarithm is and we
might just as well do that now so let's
now take a look and see what we mean by
a logarithmic function you see quite
frequently in mathematics what one does
is one deals with a particular special
case in which one is interested and
having deduced very nice results he
looks at this thing and says you know
all of these results came from a
particular recipe a particular structure
that this system obeyed what he then
does is he takes this recipe or
structure gives it a general name and
now is able to extend this property to a
larger class of objects for example
let's look at it this way what is the
nice thing about logarithms in the
traditional sense of the word remember
when we learned logarithms in high
school by use of logarithms we were able
to replace multiplication problems by
addition problems etc in other words
remember the key structural property was
that the logarithm of a product was the
sum of the logarithms that was the
structural thing that we used over and
over and over again in fact it's rather
interesting to point out that in many
cases where we use the properties of
logarithms we never really had to know
what a logarithm was all we had to know
was what what properties is it obey and
did we have a book of tables so we could
look up the logarithm when we had to
well at any rate using this as
motivation we now define a logarithmic
function specifically a function that
was called logarithmic if for all X 1 X
2 in the domain of F F of the product of
x1 and x2 is f of x1 plus f of x2 in
other words since we know what nice
properties a logarithm has let's define
any function f to be logarithmic if f of
a product is equal to the sum of the FS
ok now you see
this may sound like a pretty simple
statement but it's quite demanding in
other words notice by the way somebody
says I wonder if there are any
logarithmic functions you see notice
that by the way we began there must be
at least one logarithmic function namely
the usual logarithm who knows we know
there's at least one function which has
these properties so the set of all
logarithmic functions is certainly not
the empty set at any rate let's see what
we can deduce about any logarithmic
function well for example I claim that
if f is logarithmic f of 1 must be 0 why
is that well notice that 1 can be
written as 1 times 1 and since F of 1
times 1 is F of 1 plus F of 1 we have
what that F of 1 is equal to F of 1 plus
F of 1 therefore twice F of 1 is F of 1
and therefore by algebraic manipulation
F of 1 is 0 which by the way does check
out with the usual logarithm the
logarithm of 1 to any base B is 0
secondly if F of 1 over X is defined you
see in other words I'm not sure whether
1 over X is in the domain of F just
because X is but suppose 1 over X is in
the domain of F then F of 1 over X is
equal to minus f of X notice F of a
number is minus F of the reciprocal of
that number again a familiar logarithmic
property why does it follow from our
basic definition well notice that we
already know that F of 1 is 0 we also
know that 1 is equal to x times 1 over X
provided X is not 0 by the way if X were
0 1 over 0 wouldn't be defined so it
wouldn't be worrying about that anyway
but notice now we have what if X is not
0 f of X times 1 over X is 0 but by the
logarithmic property that's also f of X
plus F of 1 over X since these two
together add up to 0 F of 1 over X must
just be minus f of X and we'll just take
a few more properties like this
just to make sure that you see what
properties logarithmic functions have
remember again the ordinary logarithm
the logarithm of a quotient was the
difference of the logarithms again f of
x over y is equal to f of X minus f of y
why is that the case well look at f of X
over Y that says f of X times 1 over Y
but again by logarithmic properties f of
a product is the sum of the FS therefore
f of X times 1 over Y is f of X plus F
of 1 over Y but we just saw that F of 1
over Y is minus F of Y so we have this
familiar result now and finally by
mathematical induction if n is any
positive integer f of X to the nth power
is just n times f of X and the proof is
rather clear namely f of X to the nth
power when n is a positive integer means
f of X times X times X times X n times
and since the logarithmic property says
that F of a product is the sum of the FS
that's equal to f of X plus f of X plus
etc plus f of X and x and that precisely
is just n times f of X in other words
notice that our definition of a
logarithmic function simply that f of x1
times x2 is equal to f of x1 plus f of
x2 allows us to deduce all of the
familiar properties that were known to
us
in terms of the traditional meaning of
logarithm and now we come to the most
important question of today's lecture
and that is what does all of this
discussion have to do with the function
that we've called capital L of X and
that's what we'll tackle next let's take
a look and see whether capital L of X is
indeed a logarithmic function
well if f of X if L is to be a logarithm
if B is any constant in particular L of
B times X had better be equal to L of B
plus L of X that's the definition of
logarithmic now we don't know if that's
what do we have at our disposal to be
able to see whether we can solve this
problem or not how do we use in calculus
check to see whether two functions are
equal remember the standard approach is
what take the derivative of both sides
if the derivatives are equal then the
function is different and if we can show
that that constant is zero then the two
functions are equal so let's take a look
and see how that works over here first
of all let's see what the derivative of
L of BX is with respect to X and by the
way here again is the beauty of what we
mean when we say that all of the study
that we're making allows us to utilize
every fundamental result that we've
learned before we've learned that the
basic definition of L is what that if
you differentiate L with respect to the
given variable you get 1 over that
variable we want a derivative of L of BX
with respect to X now you see the idea
is the derivative of L of U with respect
to U is 1 over U you see by the chain
rule if we were differentiating L of BX
with respect to DX that would be 1 over
B X I should say by the chain rule yet
what I'm saying is if we differentiate L
of DX with respect to DX we would have 1
over DX but we're not differentiating
with respect to BX we're differentiating
with respect to X and this is where the
chain rule comes in namely we rewrite
the derivative of L of BX with respect
to X
as the derivative L of BX with respect
to be x times the derivative of BX with
respect to B and in this way we get what
the first factor is 1 over B X the
second factor is B itself remember B is
a constant and therefore the derivative
of L of BX is 1 over X on the other hand
what is the derivative of L of B plus L
of X since B is a constant the
derivative of L of B is 0 and by
definition the derivative of L of X with
respect to X is 1 over X and now you see
comparing these two results we see that
L of BX and L of B plus L of X
the same derivative hence they differ by
a constant which I'll call C in other
words notice that capital L is what I
call almost logarithmic if it weren't
for this fact this constant C in here it
would be a logarithmic function well at
any rate what do we have we know that
capital L of BX is equal to capital L of
B plus capital L of X plus some constant
C to evaluate the constant we only have
to evaluate it at one element in the
domain
let's pick X equal to one the motif
being that if X is one notice that on
the left hand side you have an L of B
term on the right hand side you have an
L of B term and they will cancel in
other words if X is 1 this equation
becomes L of B equals L of B plus L of 1
plus C from which it follows that C is
minus L of 1 C is minus L of 1 now what
do we want to see the B if C were equal
to 0 if C were equal to 0 this would be
logarithmic and all we need to make C
equal to 0 is to set L of 1 equal to 0
in other words summarizing this result
capital L of X is logarithmic if capital
L of 1 is 0 now remember we have a whole
family of owls that work what we're
saying now is let's pick the member of
the family of owls that passes through
the point 1 comma 0 and because that's
logarithmic let's give that a special
name in essence we will define this
symbol it's written Ln of X it will
later be called the natural logarithm of
X I'm trying to avoid the word logarithm
here as much as possible because I want
you to see that we haven't had to use
exponents at all in making this kind of
a definition but let's define Ln of X to
be the member of the family capital L of
X plus C which passes through the point
1 comma 0 in essence then what is
capital what is Ln of X I'll call it
natural log it's easier for me to say
the natural log of X is that function
whose derivative with respect to X is 1
over X
and characterized by the fact that what
if the input is 1 the output is 0 in
other words the graph passes through the
point 1 comma 0 again notice that in
terms of what we said earlier in today's
lesson we talked about the functions L
of X and talked about in the
differential calculus approach the curve
could go through any point on the x axis
what we're saying is now if the point on
the x axis that the curve crosses at is
1 comma 0
that's what Ln X will mean the lot the
natural log function in terms of the
integral calculus approach if the
particular a value that we choose the
fixed value that we're going to study
the area under notice that all we're
saying is pick a to be 1 and by the way
as a quick check all we're saying is
what the natural log of X is defined to
be the area under this curve as a
function of X in terms of the definite
integral that's the integral from 1 to X
DT over T and notice that if you pick X
to be 1 the natural log of 1 is the
integral from 1 to 1 DT over T and
that's 0 just as it should be ok
so at any rate now that tells me how to
define the natural log am I doing this
in terms of exponents no I am trying to
do what find a function whose derivative
with respect to X is 1 over X and I
would also like that function since it's
that close to being a logarithmic
function to be a logarithmic function in
other words this is how I invented the
function Ln of X the natural log of X
its derivative of respect to X is 1 over
X and the natural log of a product is
the sum of the natural logs and by the
way that's exactly how we use this
material let me just take a few minutes
and go over something that we already
had an answer for just to show you how
this works let me try to read arrive the
product rule using logarithms suppose U
and V are differentiable functions of X
and I want to find the derivative of U
times V with respect to X in other words
I'd like to find the
why the X okay I take the natural log of
both sides in other words I say if y
equals u times V then natural log y
equals natural log u times V okay now
what is the property the natural log
function has I deliberately chose it to
be that member of the elf family that
was logarithmic the natural log of U
times V is natural log u plus natural
log V now can I differentiate this
implicitly with respect to X you see how
all of our old stuff keeps coming up in
new context I take this equation and I
differentiate implicitly with respect to
X the derivative of the left-hand side
is 1 over Y dy DX the derivative of the
right-hand side is what well the rule of
law do with respect to U is 1 over U but
I'm differentiating with respect to X so
I must use the correction factor by the
chain rule 2 u DX and similarly the
derivative of log V with respect to X is
1 over V DV DX and now multiplying
through by Y I have obtained that dy DX
is y over u the u DX plus y over v DV DX
but remembering that Y is equal to u
times V this becomes VD u DX Plus u DV
DX and we have arrived at the familiar
product rule using logarithmic
differentiation you see the point that's
really important to stress here is that
it wasn't important whether the natural
log was an exponent or not the important
thing that we used about logarithms well
it was our high school course whether
it's going to be in our college calculus
course the important thing was what that
when we wanted to write the log of a
product it was the sum of the logs and
now the only additional fact that we
have from the calculus approach is that
the derivative of log X with respect to
X was defined to be 1 over X by the way
since there is a tendency to think of
traditional logarithms when one uses the
word logarithm if we so wanted and
there's no reason why we have to do this
if we wanted to associate a base with
the natural log system
this is just a little aside and we'll
talk about this more perhaps in the
learning exercises or in the
supplementary notes as need be but the
idea is this notice that in a
traditional logarithm system if the base
is B the base is characterized by the
fact that the log of B to the base B is
1 thus if we use e to denote the base
for the natural log whatever he is
it must be characterized by the fact
that the natural log of E is 1 and the
reason that I put the wood base in
quotation marks here is that I would
like you to observe that again if I have
never heard of the wood exponent it
still makes sense to say find the number
e such that the natural log of E is 1 in
fact I can give you two interpretations
for that number E and as a by-product
even show you why the second fundamental
theorem of integral calculus is as
powerful as it really is see the idea is
this to find what he is all we're saying
is take the curve y equals natural log X
ok look to see where the y coordinate is
1 in other words draw the line y equals
1 where that line intercepts the curve y
equals log X that x-coordinate is e in
other words the natural log of e must be
1 so this is geometrically how I would
locate e using differential calculus if
I wanted to use integral calculus notice
that the log of e by definition is what
the integral from 1 to e DT over T
that's the area of this region R now
what do I want either be I want e to be
that number that makes this area 1 in
other words I want the natural log of e
to be 1 so again in the same way that
one can think of pi as being
geometrically constructed notice I can
construct e geometrically namely again
what I take the curve y equals 1 over T
from T equals 1 bounded below by the T
axis and I keep shifting over to the
right until the area of this region
is exactly one the value the T value
that makes this area one is called e and
by the way notice again the power of
what I mean by the area approach notice
I can start now to get estimates on what
he must look like let me show you what
I'm driving at over here let's suppose
we take the curve y equals 1 over T from
1 to 2 now what do we mean by natural
log 2 natural log 2 is by definition the
area of this region here now notice that
the smallest height of this region since
the curve is y equals 1 over T the
smallest height of this region is 1/2
and the tallest height the highest
height in this region is 1 consequently
whatever the area of this region is it's
less than the area of the inscribed
rectangle it's greater than the area of
the inscribed rectangle and less than
the area of the circumscribed rectangle
now notice that both of these rectangles
have base 1 they were going from 1 to 2
the height of the inscribed rectangle is
1/2 therefore the area of the small
rectangle is 1/2 the area of the bit
rectangle it's a 1 by 1 rectangle is 1
and now what we have is that whatever
the natural log of 2 is it being the
area of this region it must be what less
than 1 but greater than 1/2 we also know
that whatever a is the log of E is equal
to 1 well let's go on a little bit
further what about the log of 4 the log
of 4 natural log of 4 is the log of 2
squared but we've already seen that one
of the properties of an exponential
function is that of a logarithmic
function is that you can bring the
exponent down as a multiplier CF of X to
the N is n f of X this becomes 2 log 2
and because the natural log of 2 is
greater than 1/2 twice the natural log
of 2 is more than 1 in other words if
log 2 is more than 1/2 twice
log 2 is more than 1 in other words if
we put these three lines together we
have the natural log of 2 is less than
and that
to log of e which in turn is less than
the natural log of four by the way
notice that since the derivative of log
X with respect to X is 1 over X and
that's positive log X is a one-to-one
function therefore if the log of 2 is
less than the log of E is less than or
I'll go for it follows that 2 must be
less than E which in turn must be less
than 4 in other words even with this
crude approximation of just inscribing
and circumscribing rectangles I can show
again without reference to exponents
that whatever the number E is the number
e defined by the fact that Ln of E is 1
that number E is some number between 2 &
4 but again we won't dwell on this too
long what I want to do now is to come
back to a summary point and at the same
time lead into the lecture for next time
recall that we began this lecture with
the problem of solving the situation
where the rate of change was
proportional to the amount present given
DM DT equals km we separated variables
and got down to the stage where the
integral of DM over m was KT plus a
constant and all we did in the rest of
today's lecture that was at all
different was we invented and
constructed the particular function
whose derivative would be 1 over m and
which had the logarithmic property in
other words we can now say that this is
the answer to the problem this problem
is explicitly solved because the natural
log function can be viewed as an area
under a curve we can construct it for
each M this is then what we managed to
do and by the way all I'm saying now is
that since the log is a one-to-one
function C its derivative is always
positive can't we talk about the inverse
function in other words notice that
another way of writing this is that a
natural log M is KT plus C M itself must
be the inverse log of KT plus C and you
see next time what we're going to do is
to explore what we mean by the inverse
log
see anyway in summarizing today's
lecture to make sure that we didn't fall
victim to all the computational details
notice that all we did was physically
motivated and necessity for inventing a
function whose derivative with respect
to X was 1 over X and from that point on
everything else that we did followed as
applications of material that came
before it's in this sense that the
course now picks up in tempo that as we
go on now we're going to be able to
cover larger globs of material in one
sitting because we will find at least
for the next several lectures that every
new topic is basically one new idea
together with all of the old recipes at
any rate until next time good bye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate